une démarche de déjà reçu dans une de
mes soirées qui s'appelait La Parisienne
à l'époque qui existe plus mais qui a
peut-être revient d'ailleurs au passage
ah mais ça m'étonnerait que la marque se
fasse payer 20000 euros c'est peut-être
quelqu'un de son entourage et dit il
vient et peut-être qui a essayé de
prendre un billet ah c'est ça je pense
ça va
il y a des chances
mais je pense que plutôt ça vient
peut-être d'un entourage peut-être
éloigné qui a dit il va venir ce soir il
a envie de sortir il a essayé de négocié
parce qu'ils savent que voilà c'est
combien ça vaut c'est déjà c'est un
sportif déjà il peut pas il doit pas
mais si c'est hors la saison je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus et moi aussi
c'est 2000 euros et je peux te dire il
reste toute la soirée après il passe le
balai dans l'air
[Rires]
tu le retrouves à 6h du matin
oh c'est cotillon
[Musique]
il est parti bon après-midi c'est pour
combien de temps d'accord
c'est pas logiquement c'est quand c'est
des people c'est quoi c'est complexe on
n'a pas trop la visite des people c'est
juste de la présence donc la présence
généralement ces deux heures c'est
pareil pour les
pareil pour les sets de DJ pareil pour
les choses ça dépend car ça dépend la
longueur du chaud si c'est trois quatre
champs mais pour les artistes pour du
people c'est pour du sportif c'est
justement justement je vais te donner
des chroniqueurs vraiment tu vas nous
dire combien ici sérieux il va nous dire
vraiment combien il vous paierez pour
aller faire une apparition
on va démarrer par Benjamin Castaldi
après il faut remettre les choses en
conditions
non c'est pas ça c'est que les la
clientèle le bol de nuts c'est une cible
quand même qui a du 18 à 40 ans on va
passer après 40 ans c'est plus l'épisode
donc voilà donc déjà
[Applaudissements]
Daniel
non mais voilà effectivement il y aura
des gens qui étaient déjà vieux quand
j'étais petit
quand tu étais petit il avait déjà 72
ans
mon chéri on va démarrer par Castaldi
combien tu donnerais pour Cassani je
vais le dire c'est quand même il est
quand même éthique humain grande gueule
mythique 3000 euros
[Applaudissements]
je pense tu reçois un coup de fil demain
[Musique]
j'ai un nom tout court monsieur
on va faire Guillaume Genton
pas mal en plus il a inventé son salaire
ici donc il y aura beaucoup de nanas qui
vont venir le voir
donc
[Musique]
il a 2 ans de carrière
[Rires]
il trouve même pas mal 3000 3000
actrice jolie glamour les bonnes cibles
pourquoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Daniel Moreau bah pareil zéro
bingo à Montluçon
de la saucisse à Montbéliard
[Applaudissements]
attends Delphine
Benjamin 3000 Delphine 3000 Guillaume
3000 Béatrice 3000 démons mais bon
combien Raymond c'est c'est le club ta
voiture
[Applaudissements]
les chéris c'est pas une manne c'est il
donne vraiment les vrais prix c'est pas
une vanne du tout ça dépend de la
grandeur de la boîte de la population où
elle est à plein de choses
on m'a proposé plus et j'avais dit non
jamais donné
moi aussi on va proposer des trucs
Gilbert Besse combien alors Gilles
Verdez c'est le problème c'est qu'il y a
deux prix il y a le prix pour son cachet
et le prix pour la sécu qui va
l'accompagner
c'est ça donc 2000 euros parce que il y
a moins 1000 € de sécu avec le plus
comment s'inscrit comment voilà déjà sur
Paris c'est compliqué
voilà combien ça coûte un Cyril Hanouna
en boîte
de nuit
on peut payer ouais ça peut ça peut
valoir jusqu'à 25 et ça peut ça dépend
en boîte de nuit
[Applaudissements]
comme ça
quelle horreur